5 gilet jaune sont actuellement reçus
ici par lé député de côte-d'or à la
permanence de fadila khattabi ces gilets
jaunes sont à l'origine de cet entretien
ils sont venus parler de leur fin de
mois difficiles et le la cherté de la
vie
un entretien jugé courtois et
constructif selon les députés
on a parlé de avec des gens au travail
ils avaient une personne retraitée et on
a parlé avec des gens qui sont en
intérim ou en situation précaire et qui
avec des salaires modestes n'arrive pas
à s'émanciper y en a qui vivait encore
chez leurs parents y en a qui n'arrive
pas à payer les réparations de la
voiture quand elle tombe en panne et
donc il faut faire plus pour eux il faut
ici à partir de vue de ces témoignages
la porter ce message et faire plus pour
eux ici et à paris nous n'avons
malheureusement pas pu connaître la
réaction des gilets jaunes ils n'ont pas
souhaité s'exprimer devant nos caméras
reste maintenant à connaître la
mobilisation des gilets jaunes et savoir
si ces différents contre-feu aussi bien
à matignon qu'ici en région en
fonctionner